SPEAKER: Data, it's being
created all the time
from devices, applications,
and their users.
Because it's digital
it's measurable,
but what about information
offline, in the physical world?
There's actionable offline data
just waiting to be discovered.
And with devices that
can capture, convert,
and send the newly
discovered data,
businesses in any
industry can start
measuring their
operations in real time
to anticipate events
proactively and to spot issues
before they become problems.
Processing this data would
be easy for a few devices,
but what about hundreds,
thousands, or even millions?
Google Cloud Platform
offers powerful tools
to capture massive volumes
of data distributed around
the world along with an easy
way to process the data,
whether it's
streaming in real time
or tucked away in your logs.
Query instantly into
what's happening
in any part of your business
with easy to use big data
tools and zero
infrastructure management.
So no matter what
your business is,
you can analyze performance
in all the places that matter.
This is the Internet of Things.
Get started today and see
how Google Cloud Platform
can extend your businesses
into a connected world.